the girag an experience so you've been
out here now you went to the UFC event
and then you did some training at aka
like when you are outside of camp say
like whenever your fight is scheduled
how much what kind of training are you
doing when you're not in camp are you
mixing it up now and trying to do a lot
of jujitsu a lot of BJJ when I'm not in
camp what I do so my my conditioning
trainer Valentino gardulla he follow me
everywhere is with me today and we just
train
strange conditioning because before that
was my weakness the condition I used to
knock everybody out at the first round
so I never trained my condition I never
took it's very serious because I used to
knock people out at the first round so
when I did my first five round I was
like wow the condition is so so
important so that's why I'm training a
lot you know
strange for sure conditioning and also
yeah when I'm not when I I don't have a
fight kickboxing fight plane I trained B
hehe I trained wrestling MMA and again
is a completely different condition it's
crazy when you when you Wester with a
guy and then you you get up and you're
trying to strike yeah now what kind of
strength and conditioning D are you
doing and how often you doing it like
say if you're if you're preparing for a
fight how many days a week do you do
strength auditioning when I'm preparing
for a fight every day every day every
day it's not of course it's not the same
training but every day I see Valentino
and we trained together yeah every day I
train more conditioning and strange more
than kickboxing really yeah I don't have
a trainer in kickboxing what that's
right yeah really people people don't
believe doesn't believe it when I say
that but I strain yourself I train
myself that since I have of course my
friend in the in France who all holed
meets for me for sure
and I can't hold meat from it myself he
owned me for me and we just talk
together we just plan a game plan
together for a fight we just saw I'm my
own coach you know that is crazy
I never be at your level yeah to be your
own cut you've never had a coach of
course I had a famous teacher teach me
after that he couldn't teach me anymore
because because of his job you know when
I when I was young and then I just moved
from the country and countries and
countries to learn to learn to learn and
then came back in France Paris and I
just turned myself that is insane how
many world champions just trained
themselves I think nobody do that sounds
great but why didn't you get another
coach I don't know because I need to
find a coach who can I don't know what
can just teach me I really don't know
that's a good question I just I don't
know why did I what I didn't found a new
coach I don't know because I thought
about making any trips to Holland or the
timeline no you know Bodo in France
sure yeah so I was raised there that's
where I started kickboxing I started
with full contact you know full contact
sure Rick Rufus was yeah really yeah why
I was watching recruit his brother
really is one of the big coaches and
yeah his name is um his brother Duke
Duke Rufus yeah yeah yeah yeah he's a
friend of mine it's great oh nice yeah
he's out of Milwaukee yes yeah Rufus
born yeah yeah so when I start off with
contact I was watching all the fighters
via jet especially a recruit first
against Rob Hammond the first and the
second was crazy crazy crazy recruit
against a nice toast contact fight so
after after Mike my first coach couldn't
teach me anymore I just float to
Amsterdam because oh yeah because of
Cameron you know in my mind I was
thinking about okay where is the best
kickboxing in the planet Hollan so I
went to Holland meteor gym was famous
because rock camera and
of Remy buchinsky sure and I went to
meet Georgie my train there maybe two
years you know I was flying Bordeaux I'm
standing during two years and yeah
the coach was countrymen not it teach me
a lot you know I learned a lot and when
I I figure out that I couldn't learn
anymore else in majority
I just went to Belgium because I met
samyamas Ruby is a very very great coach
for me is the best coach I never I never
had well why wouldn't you spend your
camps with him now why yeah because
because we meet each other at an event
in France and then I saw one of his
fighter
it was fighting and then when I saw his
technique is his condition it was you
know his first round was looking the
same at his fifth round it was crazy
a very very high level condition his
name is Muhammad in dude was very crazy
and I say that's that's like this I want
to fight right he was so technical you
know and I say that's what like this I
want to fight I went to Belgium in
Brussels and I trained with him also two
years I was driving Paris presented
Paris Brucella two years during two
years I trained with him and I that's
with Samir that I won my first Bell
against Nikolas can he if you watch my
face before Nikolas can and the fight
against achillion is completely two
different fighter so why don't you do
your camps with him now now because you
live in pure sense yeah I can't anymore
so that's why I left some you but some
is still in my corner when I fight just
come you know but I don't train anymore
with Sammy so there's no one in Paris
no northern Bordeaux that you can for me
the best the best the best trainer the
best school is in percents the
Queensbury gym and I never found another
under the team with that kind of Royal
so I cannot train with any coach you
know and
I just turned myself my friend hold meat
for me I trained with Valentino the
conditioning training for me was more
important than than the kickboxing
everybody knows the key box now we know
how to kick back but the difference we
will be make with the condition for that
it's interesting you know there's a
there's a thought process that follows
those lines in MMA and it's Marva
renovage and this guy Nick curse on and
they've only trained a few fighters but
they've had very high levels of success
because of their conditioning and what
they say is that they already know how
to fight so just go to concentrate on
the conditioning and get your
conditioning to a super-high level and
that when you're fighting you can just
go yeah that's right that's what I say
every time when I when I give advices to
to people they say what should I train
this is this technique listen between
two two fighters in the same level the
same experience what's gonna make the
difference is the condition in the fight
you know if you fight one two three
rounds and then you [ __ ] up you lose
the fight right if you fight five wrong
and even if you're not good enough
technically you're gonna win the fight
for sure because you don't get tired
yeah